Waaaaaah!
Guys, it's not donation reading.
Sorry.
Wait!
Wrong room!
Sorry!
Give me a sec.
Waaaaaah!
Okay, we're in the right room now.
Sorry.
Guys, I already forgot what room we were in.
I already forgot what room we were in for these streams, guys.
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
So scu- Oh my gosh.
It wouldn't be a Doki Bird stream without a little bit of scum.
I'm so sorry.
Today's been...
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
Alright, I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna like sugarcoat it.
I won't... I won't like, you know...
I won't lie.
Today... Today was really rough.
I'll say it.
I had a really, really rough day.
Today... Today was really rough.
But the one thing I looked forward to today, though, was being able to hang out with you dragoons.
Cause not gonna lie, even though I had a really rough day, I always look forward to streaming for you guys.
Because you guys make it all better.
And like, I always feel happy whenever I'm streaming for you guys.
And, it's just I just love like hanging out with my dragoons.
Cause you guys always make me so happy.
And like forget about the troubles and stuff.
It also helps a lot because it's like...
I get to like... Not worry about the stuff that made the day rough.
It's a little... I guess it's a little like...
Pause on like the real world shit going outside.
Sorry.
It's like, you know...
You know, like, oh if I stream right now, I don't have... and I keep streaming.
I don't have to worry about what's gonna going on until I stop my stream and then it's back to having a rough time.
It's like a symbiotic escapism.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just a really rough day today.
Just a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes and stuff.
I think okay.
I had like I think like one of the reasons why it was like super rough was because like okay.
This is a little personal.
It's a little personal.
But like I did have like a little argument.
Okay, maybe it wasn't that little.
Maybe it wasn't that little but I had an argument.
With my parents about some things.
So that's why it was like super rough and...
It's a little bit better now.
But yeah, that's why I was like, oh I can't wait to just stream.
Stream because then I can like escape from it and just spend time with my dragoons.
It's never fun.
Whenever you argue with your parents, it's never a fun time.
Because you're just like no.
And you're like yeah.
And they're like no.
And I'm like I'm going to my room.
And then you know like you go to your room and you're like and then you refuse to go out your room.
Because when you go out your room they win.
You know.
When you have those types of things.
And then you're like oh I want to.
And so guys I have not went out of my room yet.
But then eventually you have to eventually go out of your room.
And then you and your parents pretend nothing happened.
And then when you finally...
And then oh yeah you have to come out to either eat or use the bathroom.
And then when you finally do come out.
You have to go to your room.
You pretend nothing happened.
And then it's like you never had that argument in the first place.
And then...
And it's like the awkward silence.
And then they'll be like what do you want to eat?
And then you're just like I don't care.
And then...
And then the next day everything will just be fine.
You know thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you have a better day tomorrow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Of course yeah me too.
Obviously I hope I do have a better day tomorrow.
James thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The feeling is mutual.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah the social research.
Just parents things.
That's why you should never have kids.
Unless your kids subscribe to me.
Anyway.
That's why you should never have kids.
Unless those kids will become Doki Bird subscribers.
Then that's fine.
But other than that.
Because then you know when you have kids.
That's going to happen to you too.
Where you're going to have the same thing.
Those exact same arguments.
And then you'll realize.
Oh my god my parents were right.
I was a piece of shit.
But for now I want to think that I'm right.
For now I want to think that I'm right.
And I don't have the knowledge.
Of what it's like to be a parent.
To realize.
Wow.
My fucking kid is a piece of shit.
I do not want to enforce.
The circle of life right now.
I like to live with the ignorance.
That I am the perfect child.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad that streaming and hanging out with the dragoons.
Helps you get away from the stress.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I quit the cycle.
Um.
But yeah.
I hope the music isn't.
Too loud guys.
I hope the lo-fi is.
Comfy.
I really like doing these.
I know this is only my second stream.
On the late night radio.
The late night radio shows.
But I'm honestly already starting to.
Really enjoy it.
Because it's just.
It's just a nice time to just hang out.
Like be real with you guys.
Just talking.
And having a conversation.
With my dragoons.
And it's always a nice time.
And I hope that it helps with your sleep.
Or it's a nice like.
It's a nice like good morning for those people on the other side of the world.
I can up the music a little bit.
If people can't hear it.
I hear some people are like what music?
No.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Screw YouTube for kids.
Subscribe to Doki Bird for all your child distracting entertainment.
Yes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you have a child and they are becoming an iPad kid.
You might as well.
Like they are already fucked mentally.
Because they are becoming iPad kids.
If you guys don't know.
Like okay.
No matter what my content will always be better than Coco Melon.
Because apparently.
I talked about this before.
But Coco Melon.
And like a lot of like kids channels.
Are known to actually harm your child's brain development.
So no matter what.
I cannot be worse than that.
Like.
At best.
They will learn some profanity.
But they were going to learn it eventually.
So you might as well start them off young.
Like you don't want them to suddenly learn it from their friends.
Cause like if their friends.
Cause then that means their friends are bad influences.
But if they learn from me.
At least you know.
It's not because of a bad influence.
It's because it's just so natural.
In my vocabulary.
That I'm not going to be a bad influence.
That is just part of how I speak.
Like.
Cause like.
You don't want your child.
To learn fuck.
From their friends.
Cause like.
What would the context be?
But then.
You know if your child learns fucking fucking.
From me.
It's just part of an expression.
It just means.
Like a lot of something.
So it's not.
Not part of whatever context.
Whatever bad influence.
That their friends are doing to your child.
You know for me.
I'm a good influence.
Because even though I'm stupid.
Um.
Even though I'm stupid.
I'm not influencing.
I'm not like.
I'm not fucking.
With your child's development.
Ten minutes passed.
I should be okay I think.
Um.
You did the swears.
And it's nine minutes.
Thank you for the super chat Jonathan.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah as a parent.
I'm thankful that the realization.
That used to be a rude dumb fuck.
Happened before I had a kid.
Now I'm mostly a nice dumb fuck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look.
All I'm saying.
Is that.
If you have children.
Please make sure to have them subscribe.
To Doki Bird.
Uh.
So I can get a million subscribers.
Honestly at this rate.
I don't think I'm going to get a million subscribers.
Before the end of the year.
Unless I hit the algorithm hard.
I don't think it's possible.
It's.
I'm looking at like.
I actually calculated the.
Cause like okay.
The reason why.
You guys must be like wow Doki.
Why are you calculating.
When you're going to hit a million subscribers.
It's cause like at a million.
I want to make a huge.
I'm planning a huge project.
For a million.
But the thing is.
I need to know when I hit a million.
So I can debut this.
So I can pinpoint the timing of the project.
For a million subscribers.
I haven't started the plans for a million.
But I need to know.
When will I hit it.
So I can calculate.
How many months of planning.
I need to do for a project.
For a million subscribers.
So.
So that's why.
Like I'm trying to.
I need to know exactly.
Cause it's like oh my gosh.
If I like plan it advance.
Like way too advance.
And I have it done.
By before I hit a million.
But then like so many things happen.
Afterwards.
And I hold on to this project.
For like I don't know.
Half a year after it's completed.
Then it'll be outdated.
I don't want something to be outdated.
So like that's why I'm trying to like.
I always like try to figure out when I hit.
It's also like subscriber milestones too.
I've been trying to like figure out.
I think like at 800k subscribers.
There's something I want to do.
I hit 800k subscribers.
But like.
I also.
I'm also worried that.
It would take too long.
I'm a little worried.
That it's gonna take a little bit too long.
Because.
And now I'm like.
Oh it's gonna be so outdated.
But.
Like I would be like so impatient.
Because I would rather just debut the project.
That I had planned for 800k earlier.
Than just waiting for 800k.
It's just like wait.
I'm just like impatient.
Like I'm just like waiting.
I'm very impatient on things.
Case in point.
There's like things.
I.
I told you guys.
There's things I watch.
And there's things that I like.
Maybe I don't play a particular game or something.
But I like want to know the ending of something.
Oh yeah.
If I play a game.
This is very very rare.
Not JK.
I lie.
But there's a game I haven't really played.
Or uh.
I haven't really played.
Or I'm not looking interested in playing.
But I want to know the plot or story.
Of the game.
I would actually look up the ending.
Because like.
I know I won't play it.
Like I know I won't play the game.
So like.
But I'd be like.
Oh I want to know how the.
It's like JRPGs.
But like.
There's like some JRPGs.
That like I'm curious about.
Like I'll be like.
Oh what's gonna happen.
What's the story.
And stuff like that.
So I just like look it up.
And I'll be like.
Oh okay.
But like JRPGs is such a terrible example for me.
Because it's so fucking long.
That you get sucked into a rabbit hole.
I think that I only done that for like.
One JRPG.
And it was for.
No two.
It was the one with the lightning.
With lightning as the main character.
And the other one was like one of the personas.
Because like I remember like I quit.
Playing the lightning one.
Because it was terrible.
Like there's nothing else I can really say.
Other than you know.
It was pretty bad.
Like.
I played up until.
I played up until like.
I think like.
I played like one to two hours.
And then I was like.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like this is not for me.
Because like I remember telling you guys.
Like oh these were the JRPGs I played.
Like Final.
Because you guys were like.
Have you ever played Final Fantasy.
And I was like yes.
There's only been two Final Fantasys that I've played and touched.
And like apparently.
One of the worst installments.
In Final Fantasy.
But they were literally the two games that I tried.
Like I would be like.
Let's give Final Fantasy a shot.
And then one of them was the one with the three girls.
I don't remember their names.
The one with the three girls that were the main characters.
And apparently that was supposed to be a sequel.
To the game before.
To the last Final Fantasy game.
But I played that.
Yeah X2.
That was my very first Final Fantasy game.
And then I tried to play it.
And I was like.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Because it's a sequel.
But I didn't realize it was a sequel.
I had.
I was very young as well.
So I really had like no clue.
It was a sequel.
But I was like.
I remember going to like EB games.
And then like.
For those who don't know what EB games.
It's like EA games.
But like B for Canadian.
Anyway.
And then I saw that.
I was like.
Dad I wanna buy this.
Because Final Fantasy.
It's everywhere.
And then.
And then you know.
I tried it.
Didn't know what the fuck is going on.
I think it's also because when I was younger.
I was mega illiterate.
Versus now.
Which is like illiteracy by choice.
Uh.
Back then.
It was because.
I was just really stupid.
And I was like sort of illiterate.
And I like didn't really know how to read.
But now it's by choice.
That I don't read.
And anyway.
Um.
Anyway.
And then a couple of years passed by.
Like a hundred years passed by.
Oh my god Doki.
How old are you?
A hundred years passed.
It felt like a hundred years.
And then the lightning one.
Final Fantasy 13.
That's the lightning game.
Came out.
And I was like.
Let me give it another shot.
Maybe like you know.
Maybe it was just the game.
And it wasn't me.
You know.
Maybe like you know.
Little Doki just.
Back then little Doki just wasn't into JRPGs.
And now slightly older Doki.
Will be okay with it.
Because I'm more mature.
And like possibly I could read a little better.
Um.
And possibly the more mature you are.
And by the way.
TikTok hasn't been invented yet.
Nor has Vine been invented yet.
So like my attention span.
Is still decent.
Uh.
So like.
I haven't got like fucked over.
By like the lack of an attention span.
Because none of the short form content.
Existed yet.
It was like long form content meta.
Still.
So like it was still let's play meta.
Where people would watch like one hour let's play videos.
Because the ten minute shit hasn't hit yet.
Um.
Anyway.
Uh.
So I was like alright.
The fantasy 13 came out.
So.
I was like alright.
Let's.
Oh my god.
Lightning.
Oh I saw an advertisement.
On about her.
Where she like modeled some.
Louis Vuitton bags.
And she was like a model and everything.
Oh my god.
It can't be that bad.
Hahahaha.
Anyway.
So I tried.
I tried Final Fantasy 13.
And.
And then obviously.
We all know the reputation.
Of Final Fantasy 13.
Hahahaha.
But at that time.
I was like maybe it's just me.
Hahahaha.
You know.
Maybe I was like I didn't know it was considered.
Bad bad.
Because also at that time I didn't really look at reviews.
I was just like.
It was just like.
Experience wise.
So I stopped after.
I think like after like.
Like one to two hours.
I stopped and I was like.
Oh man.
Final Fantasy.
Is just sucks for me.
Hahahaha.
I was just like.
Oh man Final Fantasy.
Maybe it's just sucks.
Hahahaha.
And then.
After that.
I never touched.
I think like after that.
I never like touched JRPGs again.
Oh no that's a lie.
I tried to play Persona as well.
And then I realized.
I think like after I played Persona.
And I tried to play the Persona.
The one that came out on the Playstation.
Hahahaha.
And then.
Um.
After.
Okay but like what are the odds.
That would play two of the.
Two of the worst.
Like games in the franchise.
Like.
What were the fucking odds.
That that would be me.
Hahahaha.
It's like similar.
Similar to how.
I told you guys.
For some fucking reason.
I managed to watch.
Two.
I've only been to two.
Cirque du Soleil shows.
And for some fucking reason.
I managed.
To watch the same show.
Twice.
From Cirque du Soleil.
How?
There was a 15 plus year gap.
Between two.
Both of those shows.
But it happened to be the same show.
I couldn't believe it.
Hahahaha.
For those who didn't hear the story.
I told this story.
On the stream.
I think with.
With Gumi.
And what happened.
Was that when I was really young.
I went to see a Cirque du Soleil show.
And it was this show.
I remember it very well.
Because I bought the soundtrack of it.
I bought the soundtrack of the show.
And so I was like.
Oh shit.
Hell yeah.
I fucking listened to that on my fucking.
Iphone.
It was in my iTunes.
And my Iphone.
So I remember the song so well.
Because it was like 15 plus years.
Of listening to that song.
To those songs.
When they play on shuffle.
And then.
Like 15 plus years later.
I realized.
Oh my god.
Maybe not even 15.
I swear it could be longer.
It could be 20 years.
Honestly I will not be.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even know how long.
And I need you guys to know.
How many shows Cirque du Soleil has.
Cirque.
I'm going to look it up right now.
Cirque du Soleil.
That shit pissed me off so much.
I couldn't believe it.
Because I bought VIP.
I bought like front row seats.
For the second one.
Just to re-watch the same thing.
Blade Wing.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you for some fucking reason.
You happen to be the best Vtuber in the world.
And I can't fucking believe it.
So keep doing what you do forever.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that you think that way of me.
Alright.
Now I need to look.
I need to tell you guys.
Because I looked it up.
I couldn't believe it.
I actually looked this up.
Because I was like.
I couldn't fucking believe.
That I managed to re-watch this fucking show.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
I like counted too.
I was like.
How many shows have they done?
And they've done like.
I remember counting it.
I looked up on the Wikipedia.
And I literally counted how many shows they've done.
They've done.
They've done 53 different shows.
And I somehow managed to watch the same one twice.
I, it pissed me off so.
Okay anyway as I saying.
So yeah so I bought.
Like I was like.
I haven't seen Cirque du Soleil in so fucking long.
Like modern times.
So I was like.
Oh shit.
I'm gonna go watch Cirque du Soleil.
Because obviously I would think it'd be a new show.
If it's touring again.
So...
They're touring again!
They always- they tour so much and they always come up with new things!
So how the fuck was I supposed to know that they will redo the same thing 15 years- 15 to 20 years ago?
Anyway, so yeah I remember I paid for the the one of the more really expensive tickets because I wanted to be at the front at the front because I hate sitting in the back because like My eyes aren't as good as it used to be and I know I wear glass Okay,
not- okay, it might not look like I'm wearing glasses right now But like when I watch things I wear my glasses like yeah, like you I can still see it But like I like seeing their- their like I could like seeing their Expressions and their faces because usually there's no second or third screen because it's a circus If you guys don't know but yeah,
I paid for a fucking rerun uh Like for Cirque du Soleil, they don't have like additional screens where you can zoom in on the faces and stuff Like you it's just like if you sit in the back, it's just little fucking stick figures So I didn't want to see that I was like,
I really want like like experience the circus and like Experience like what they're what they're feeling when they're performing and so I was like I ain't buying the back seats I'm buying the front seats because I don't want to see fucking seats I don't want to see like the big stick figures trying to perform stuff because it's not as impressive when they're so far away Like I might as well just watch it on TV because at least a TV or DVD or the YouTube video has like close-ups Like okay,
this is my opinion but like I rather just watch if I'm gonna watch something live I rather have watch it like in the front rather than the back unless it's like a huge concert thing I don't know I think like concerts that's sort of different because For con- performances,
it's a different story But like concerts I'm fine with concerts if I'm sitting in that back cuz it's all about the music and like there's usually like screens or close-ups and stuff of The performances, but if it's like musicals entertainment Circuses stuff like that They usually don't have an extra screen where you can like see what's going on close up So like if I if I rather just sit in the front where I can see what the fuck is going on Then the back cuz if I can't do that I might as well just watch the thing on TV or like watch it on YouTube Anyway
So yeah, I bought I got this in the front and I heard the first song I heard the- I even bought like overpriced pretzels and coke too I even spent money on overpriced concert food and Cuz that pretzel was so fucking dry and it was like 15 Canadian dollars so for you Americans,
it's like five dollars
So you Americans out there it's like nothing for you guys but for us it's like 15 Canadian
Anyway, I bought a fucking- I bought an overpriced dry as fuck pretzel and And an overpriced bottle of coke just so watch a rerun and I was so fucking mad
I heard the first song and I was like wait I know this song.
Why do I know this song?
And shit like I was like I was like in denial at first I was like I'm still coping and being like, why do I know this song?
There's no way I know this song.
And then after like the first 30 seconds, I was like, oh my god, no, no.
So...
So yeah, I was in denial and then I was like bargaining and then anger.
I'm sort of still like in... I'm still sort of like going through the five stages of grief at the moment.
It's been months, but I'm still going through the five stages of grief by the way.
I felt so betrayed, chat.
I felt so fucking betrayed.
But yes, I feel like I'm just a very unlucky person.
Sometimes I feel like okay, I'm either like...
I'm either... I'm so... I know, I know.
I am very unlucky.
I'm incredibly unlucky person and a...
Time?
Sometimes I'm like lucky is because I like work for it.
When I get something or like if something good happens to me is because I work so hard that it counteracts my unluckiness.
I feel...
Hanta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you ever thought you're really really clumsy?
Like that's a talent in the worst ways, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Delta, thank you for the super chat.
Some locations across the world do specific shows only.
No, no.
The Cirque du Soleil's I've seen were the touring ones.
That's the worst part.
Like coincidentally, all the Cirque du Soleil...
Like the two Cirque du Soleil shows I watched were the ones that they decided to tour in my city.
And that was the worst part.
Just the touring shows.
So 15 years?
The touring show is this... yeah.
50 to 20 years!
They decided to tour again?
Anyway, Delta.
Oh yeah, I already said that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If we watch something twice, are we then the blooms?
13 years.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I don't think I'll ever be able to see a new Cirque du Soleil.
Now I'm afraid.
Because I don't remember the name of the show I watched.
The worst part is that I actually don't remember the show that I watched.
And I feel like if I try to watch Cirque du Soleil again for the third fucking time...
I'm gonna just pay... I'm gonna...
I will not be surprised if it's the third fucking time.
It's the third time.
Mahk me welcome to the...
Welcome back to the tomato farm.
Welcome back.
That's a me problem.
Let's see...
But yeah anyway, that's what I'm saying like...
Oh my gosh, how did I get to this fucking tangent?
Oh, yeah, it's because of my...
It's because of how unlucky I was for...
Oh my god!
Anyway, I don't know if you guys know this.
I tweeted this out.
I tweeted this out, but like...
There was like major fucking leaks in the animation...
In the animation sector.
So for those who don't know...
I really, really love animation and like animated shows.
I watched a lot of them over the years.
Because I honestly...
Especially for drama stuff, for drama shows...
I cannot do live action drama shows quite well.
Because I just get so depressed.
And...
I get so depressed.
And like I'm already...
You know, I'm already having a rough time.
Like...
I...
It's why like I said this before...
But I normally watch like comedies, animation...
Or like just things that are like super light-hearted.
And I tend to avoid drama stuff.
And like I usually avoid like gore and things.
Like I actually...
I hate the gore in Invincible.
I hate it so much.
But like I understand like...
In the show...
Like it needs that.
But like I always look away when the gore is coming in for Invincible.
Because I can't handle that stuff.
Like I actually look away.
And like...
And wait until it's over.
Because like I'm like bro, life is already very depressing.
And I don't...
I don't need more of that.
And like...
Oh my...
Okay, also I...
I don't understand people who complain.
The thing is...
Okay, you guys don't know this.
But for those...
Like some people might not know this.
I actually read the Invincible comics.
And I didn't finish reading it.
I think I read like...
I read the ending of the comics for Invincible.
And I read like...
I think like a couple of chapters in the beginning of Invincible.
But...
Anyway...
And like I know like the major plot points in the comics too.
So like I know like what's gonna happen in the comics.
But anyway...
Um...
Apparently...
People who like read the Invincible comics...
They were complaining about how little the gore was.
I was like...
Are you fucking kidding?
They were like...
You guys toned it down so much.
And I'm like...
What?
What do you mean?
I was just like...
You want more?
But if we had more...
The fucking ratings for that show would be like R18 at that point.
Wait is it Invincible?
Okay what is Invincible's rating?
Invincible...
Rating...
Uh...
Ratings for...
What is it?
Parental rating?
I don't even know what it's called.
Oh it's mature.
Yeah that's not even R18.
It's mature.
But like I'm pretty sure...
If we go further...
It would have been like...
R...
It would have been like R18.
I was like...
It was already too much for me.
And like they added moments in there.
They added in there.
That was like...
I was like...
What the fuck?
Yeah they said like...
The people were complaining.
The like hardcore comic readers...
Were complaining that like...
They didn't go like hard enough.
And I was just like...
Are you...
What?
What do you...
I...
I was like...
Bro I wish they toned it down.
Bro I...
What do you mean?
It was...
Oh my...
I...
Like...
Bro...
Sometimes I wanna eat when I watch this show.
Like...
I...
Sometimes...
Sometimes I want...
Yeah but like...
M for Mature is...
Isn't M for Mature...
Like...
Less than R18?
Cause like R18 is like a different...
Isn't it go like...
Uh...
Um...
What was it?
Parental Rating Guide.
Okay I need to look at the Parental Rating Guide.
I'm pretty sure 18 is the top.
And then Mature is below that.
That's for video games?
There's different rating guides?
Bro...
I can't keep up with this.
Like...
I can't...
Why can't it be universal?
I don't understand.
I...
Like...
Why can't just things be universal?
Just like how...
How English is like one of the universal languages.
We don't want like English 2.
Oh wait...
British is English 2.
And that is why the British aren't the universal language.
This is why!
This is why we don't acknowledge British English and every time we're like how do you spell this?
Okay that's not true because...
Is it f***ed up for me to say that like that's not true because the UK has...
UK has sort of forced a lot of other countries to adopt the way of spelling in the UK like color.
Like okay, like in Canada we spell color with C-O-L-O-U-R.
But I feel like we've sort of stopped doing that because people make fun of us.
Like the Americans make fun of us whenever we do spell color that way.
We spell it that way because I don't spell it like that anymore.
I've like assimilated into like Into like mainstream universal English.
I feel like the Americans are wrong.
Anyway, why the fuck is there different?
There is?
There's video games, movies, television, music, com- There's- what?
There's a max rate?
Okay, that's funny.
In comic books instead of like Mature, it's max.
Like for explicit content.
That's pretty- Okay, that's That's funny that they don't even say mature.
It's like Max com...
Max explicit content, alright.
Okay, so in video games, it's Adults only with the A.
It's mature and then A for adults only and then for a television That it's mature audience.
Oh shit!
Okay.
No.
Okay, so the highest is mature.
In Television.
In movies, it's restricted R and then NC-17.
Oh!
May include violence, sex, behaviors, or any other elements that most parents would consider too mature for viewing by their children.
Alright!
That's good to know.
I wish it was universal.
Because it makes it so much more complicated.
Yeah, that's just way too complicated in my opinion.
I'd rather it just be a universal thing.
Because like...
We already have so many things to worry about, man.
We already have a lot of things.
Anyway, what was I saying?
How did I fucking...
How did I get to this topic?
Oh my gosh, where was I?
Oh no, my tangents have its own tangents now.
We're in too deep.
Oh yeah, animation.
Sorry.
I was supposed to... I was talking about animation.
So...
Recently, there has been a giant animation leak.
Where...
Somebody who... I don't know.
Some fucking insider at Disney basically leaked a lot of pilots, a lot of scripts, a lot of like, pitch bibles, and a lot of like, canceled show episodes.
On like, anonymous forums.
And it was... Okay.
I read the story behind it.
It was so funny.
So I think like, one of the main discoverers...
was like, some Gravity Falls fan.
That was like, oh my god, guys.
Somebody leaked everything.
On like, Twi... Like, they're like...
Talking about it on Twitter.
And then people were like...
What?
What's going on?
And I was like, reading the story.
Cause I was like...
What... How did all this get leaked?
So apparently, there was a thread.
And it was on an anonymous forum.
And there was a thread that was like...
Um...
Oh my god, here's a leak.
And then some other guy was like...
That's a shitty leak.
Anyway...
Look, here are all these other shows.
These other shows that are so much better than this leak that I'm leaking.
And I was like...
That's...
That's so fucking funny.
Cause they're like...
They're like...
Fuck that leak.
That's a shitty one.
Let me show you a good leak.
And then he proceeded to link...
He proceeded to link...
Like, link...
All...
Like, a bunch of like...
Unaired episodes.
And then later on, he was like...
Even better.
Here's some more links.
And I was like...
What?
Oh my god.
And then...
And then he was like...
They just started...
Non-stop...
Like...
There was like a leak war.
I mean, like...
Who has the better Disney leak?
And it was all like...
Disney-centric.
Cause like...
The...
The thread started talking about like...
A Disney...
Like an unaired Disney pilot.
And...
And then obviously Twitter found out.
And was like...
Oh my god.
These like Twitter...
Like...
TV show stands found out.
And like...
Especially Gravity Falls.
Cause that fucking fandom...
Is very...
Um...
It's like...
It's...
The fact that it's still incredibly fanatic...
Even after the show...
Had only two seasons.
If you guys didn't know...
Gravity Falls technically only had...
Two seasons.
And...
It...
It ended...
Let's see how long ago...
How long did Gravity Falls end in?
It ended in tw...
What?
Wait...
Oh my god.
Okay.
It ended on...
Twenty-third...
Okay.
2016.
Oh my gosh.
Is it 2016?
Yeah.
It ended on like...
2016?
Yeah.
Really?
Oh my god.
I need to like...
Double check my information at that point.
It ended on 2016.
Oh my god.
Eight years.
And the fandom is still going incredibly strong.
And like...
I'm not surprised that it was like...
A Gravity Falls fan on Twitter.
That made it like...
That brought the attention of it.
And then...
So like...
So then this...
Another...
So then like...
People started compiling everything that came from that thread.
And...
They were like...
Freaking out.
And was like...
Oh my...
Anyway.
So I like...
Looked at the...
I looked at the...
There's like a folder with all of it.
And...
I was so sad.
Because...
Okay.
It was actually so interesting.
Because...
It talks about like...
People pitching their ideas.
For...
Disney pilots.
For like...
Disney animated pilots and stuff.
And there was like...
Four different people.
And...
Four animators.
That tried to make DuckTales.
I thought that was so interesting.
Four different...
Animators.
Like...
Four different showrunners.
Try and pitch.
Their own version.
Of DuckTales.
And I actually...
I was like...
Reading all four of them.
And the one that we got was the most interesting.
It was actually like...
If you read the pitch bible.
The most interesting one.
And most creative one.
Out of the four.
The one that...
Because I think two of them was just based off of the original show.
And it was just being a continuation of the original show.
I don't remember... the third one was also sort of creative.
But the one they picked that became DuckTales, the pitch bible was like really creative.
And actually put their own spin.
Because it wasn't just... a lot of the DuckTales one was just a sketch and then words.
And then like a huge blurb of words.
And being like, blah blah blah.
This show is gonna start out as blah blah blah blah blah.
But then the one that became the DuckTales reboot that we got was like an actual comic.
I was like, ooh!
Majority pictures!
I like that as somebody that doesn't like to read.
I was like, ooh!
This catches my attention.
It's mature... mostly visual!
Nijinai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I pooped a nose and now I go to sleep.
Work on Sunday is always exciting.
Hope you had nothing but fun and good times with chat.
Bye bye!
Also feel old because the PS2 is 24 years old this year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, the PS2 has graduated university and is trying to look for its first job.
Oh my god.
Okay, but it was actually interesting.
It was so interesting because they got really creative with their pitch bible.
Anyway, within the leaks, there was also Darkwing Duck as well.
And there was also Darkwing Duck and it was also like saying...
Because it was going to be a reboot of Darkwing Duck.
And it was going to be like a spiritual...
It was going to be like a reboot of Darkwing Duck and it was going to be like a spiritual...
It was going to like follow up from DuckTales.
But apparently that got shelved and cancelled.
If you guys didn't know, I was tweeting about it also.
But like Disney animation is known to only make three seasons.
Because like for them, analytic wise and research wise, uh when they...
Three seasons is like the maximum that Disney will usually go in terms of like financing.
Because they're really scared that by season four, uh...
They're really scared that season four will lose money.
And...
Three seasons to them, they think is like the optimal lifespan for any animated show.
Um...
Because it's like they don't know how...
They don't want to go to four.
Because they don't think they make profit.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You call that a leak?
This is a leak.
Yeah.
And like the thing...
Okay, the thing I don't understand is that a lot of the...
Okay, the thing is...
It really sucks too.
Because a lot of these shows, they do really well with like...
Queens and up.
I'll say.
Kids don't like these shows.
You can say like kids are not like a super huge fan of like the shows that we considered we would like.
Like Gravity Falls was really good.
I really liked Gravity Falls.
I really liked The Owl House.
I really liked...
Star Vs.
The Forces of Evil.
But we don't talk about the last season.
Okay, apparently people blame Star Vs.
The Forces of Evil last season 4 as the one the main reason why they don't do season 4 anymore.
There won't...
There won't be reasons This is why they don't let us do season 4.
Because...
Stars vs.
The Forces of Evil got a season 4.
And like they lost a lot of money.
So it like backed up Disney's ideas of like we never do a season 4.
Because look at what they did.
Like look at what they did in season 4.
Do you want your show to be like that?
So they...
And someone... I remember like when I tweeted it out.
So I was like, oh it wasn't cancelled.
They never had a plan to do season 4.
They actually did.
It's just that it was super common knowledge for the animation team.
Like in Disney.
To know that...
Most shows tend to not get a season 4.
That they had like a backup plan.
Because like they had a backup plan to being like...
Okay.
If we don't get renewed...
Then like this is how we're gonna end it.
If our show doesn't get renewed.
Like this is always gonna be how we're gonna end this show.
And it felt like...
I honestly felt like it was super rushed too.
And...
And even then the animation team was like...
Oh yeah like if we had more seasons...
I would wanna do this.
I would like love to do that.
And then they were planning on having a season 4.
And then...
DuckTales and then having...
And then after season 4 is over.
That's when they end it.
And then they'll do Darkwing Duck.
But they never did that.
Because Disney was like...
Not enough money.
But the...
But the main reason is that they don't make merch.
That's what pisses me off the most.
The only reason why Teen Titans Go has like 500,000 seasons.
Is that they spam so much fucking merch for Teen Titans Go.
None of these other Disney shows make merch.
And like...
That's what pisses me off.
Because they're like...
We don't get enough support for...
Oh yeah and Infinity Train.
I fucking love Infinity Train.
They're like...
We don't...
The shows you love.
That you want us to make another season.
We don't get enough...
We don't get enough profit from that.
Because nobody's buying anything.
Buy what?
What do you want us to buy?
The fucking one dollar comic book?
Like...
Where?
I go to a toy store.
It's Teen Titans Go.
Where the fuck is the Owl House?
Buy the thing you don't make.
Exactly.
There's like...
It's always merch.
But what merch?
Like...
What do we buy?
There's so much...
But then they're like...
Oh...
But...
If we make the merch...
No one's going to buy it.
Because our data shows...
That...
Like...
It's just a loss of profit.
If we do make that merch.
What data?
What fucking data?
If you don't make any...
What data do you have?
What do you make?
Anyway...
It's crazy.
But they're willing to make the 500 fucking lightsaber for Star Wars.
It's just...
Oh man.
That's why I'm so sad whenever shows get cancelled.
Like get like not renewed or...
Shows I enjoy.
I really miss DuckTales.
Woohoo.
Ba da ba dum ba bum ba da DuckTales.
Yeah.
They made merch for Grav...
Barely.
Like it wasn't like...
They barely did made merch for Gravity.
Gravity Falls.
Okay, Gravity...
Falls.
You see more shit for fucking Teen Titans go than you did Gravity Falls.
To be fair, the show is over though.
But like...
I feel like there...
It did not exist as much as like the other stuff going on there.
Like especially like a lot of merch they made for Gravity Falls was not gear towards children.
They were clearly gear towards like...
Millennials.
Like that's the issue.
Like...
They're like, if this merch does not sell for children, there's no point in selling anything.
And because of that, there's no point in... there's... this show does not make any profit.
That's their data!
If the fucking shows... if the merch doesn't sell enough for children, they're like, it's not profitable.
I still buy toys Disney, but yeah!
When a company is run by like, 60 year old grandpas, who sometimes... who some of them still think animation is for children, they just be like, it's not profitable because kids don't want to buy it.
Have you seen the kingdom hearts pilot episode for disney's channel?
It's on YouTube.
Moose, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
I don't remember... I think I had I think I have, but I'm pretty sure I don't remember much of it.
But I've also saw the Sailor Moon American Sailor Moon cartoon.
And that one was a little silly too.
I think the American Sailor Moon cartoon was also a little silly.
So I'm glad that they just brought over the Japanese Sailor Moon.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To be fair, we rather have three seasons than 13.
They tend to become a shell of their former selves the longer they go on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That is true, but if there's still more of the story to tell, I don't see why.
If the writers have more of the stories they want to tell...
I think it's different when the show itself is not a story.
It's more of a serialized show.
The reason why a lot of shows don't have any progression...
That's different.
A lot of the actual good animated shows...
Will have a progression of storyline.
And where characters age.
Because a lot of them don't go...
It's very uncommon for reruns to go.
That's why a lot of shows tend to have characters that just do what they want.
And they do not grow up for animation.
Because they can put reruns of that forever.
And ever.
So there's no progression.
And...
Because there's no progression, they can just put random episodes for a rerun.
It's why The Simpsons and Family Guy...
They're all fucking the same age forever.
They never age up.
So they can just put random Simpsons episodes.
Or random Family Guy episodes.
Because there's no character progression for anybody.
Or character development for anybody.
They're just the same person.
But what if this happens?
Or what if that happens?
I'm so bitter about where they ended the original Teen Titans.
They're never going to bring it back.
Because to them it's not profitable.
Because they're like...
Who bought the merch?
They never made merch until Teen Titans go.
What the fuck do you mean?
Like...
They only started making actual shit for Teen Titans the moment Teen Titans go dropped.
What do you mean?
Anyway...
Yeah, OG Teen Titans is amazing.
But they're never going to bring it back.
Because children like Teen Titans go more.
Like...
It's just more appealing to watch for little kids.
I talked about this before.
I feel like...
Sorry.
Every time I talk about animation I go in a long-ass tangent.
But like...
This is one of my favorite memes about Teen Titans go.
Like...
Okay.
Schedule.
Let me see if I can find it.
I'll show it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
This is one of my favorite...
This is one of my favorite memes about Teen Titans go.
But this is...
I showed this...
I talked about this before.
But this is how profitable Teen Titans go was.
Like...
This was...
This was the Teen Titans go schedule.
It's like...
Teen Titans go.
And then he gives a shout.
Whoa!
Teen Titans go island.
Island adventure.
Oh my...
And then there are two episodes of Steven Universe.
Good for them.
Good for them for putting that two episodes in.
Like...
Oh my god.
Wow.
They gave Steven Universe a fucking bone.
Put two episodes at 7.30pm.
You know what?
It's good that they try to diverse a little bit.
You know?
Peter, thank you for the video.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Could be worse.
Batman Beyond didn't get comics until a decade later.
The live action movie was also canned in the 2000s.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They also can the animated movie that's gonna be in the same style as like...
The Spider-Verse one too.
Uh...
Yeah.
They were...
They also cancelled that if you guys don't remember.
Because it was...
It was just...
They just didn't think it would be profitable.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two episodes of Steven Universe before Steven Universe goes on hiatus again.
Thoughts on Codename Kids Next Door?
So sad that they never made that sequel.
I remembered when the creator of Codename Kids Next Door made a whole fucking...
What's that word called for like...
Um...
What's that word when they do like a whole like online puzzle game?
What's that word called?
There's a special word for it.
Uh...
What's it called when they...
It's like it's online...
ARG!
Yeah.
Uh...
ARG.
So like if you guys didn't know the creator...
I was there for it.
Because I was also like super into...
I was and still am super into kids...
I mean I don't know if still am is like the right word to say.
But I still miss it.
But um...
The creator of Kids Next Door made a whole ARG for the Galactic Next Door.
Which was considered a sequel to the Kids Next Door.
And like a lot of like the original voice actors and the um...
And like the crew were willing to come back to it.
And he made a whole ARG to get like fan support.
Uh...
To...
To get fan support to try and like persuade the executives at Cartoon Network.
To like greenlit like a sequel.
And like when you saw the ARG...
It unlocks the...
The...
Like the pilot...
I guess like the pilot episode or something.
For...
For the Galactic...
Next Door.
And it was so cool.
Cause I was doing the ARG with everybody too.
And I was like super hyped for it.
But nothing happened!
Nothing happened!
Does Kids Next Door even have merch?
Obviously it doesn't.
Cause why don't we don't have a sequel.
But at least it went more longer than three seasons.
At least we got six seasons of that.
But I would have loved to have a Galactic Kids Next Door.
I felt like that was like a missed opportunity.
Um...
If they do it now...
They're just gonna be like banking on nostalgia.
And like it's not gonna be the same.
It's just gonna be flash animated.
And I don't want that.
I feel like...
It's gonna feel like so different.
Like I feel like it's gonna be...
It's just gonna feel weird.
Um...
Like I...
It's just gonna feel like super weird.
I feel like...
I feel like the budget wouldn't be the same.
It's like when like...
What is it?
Okay.
It's like...
Like flash can be good.
Flash animation can be good.
But I feel like after a long time...
Um...
I mean like obviously...
Wait, flash is dead.
What's the newest one?
Um...
But like it can be good.
Because like My Little Pony was done on...
How was it?
Was it done on flash?
No, it...
What was the...
What was the program they used?
But like if you guys didn't know...
The Friendship is Messed Magic episodes...
Oh my god.
The budget for that shit was insane.
Oh yeah, Toon Boon.
Um...
But okay.
Ah...
Budget per episode.
It got really...
I was like reading up the budget...
Budget for each one.
Six million!
What?
Okay.
Um...
What?
Okay.
It's like...
Wow...
Okay.
How much is it?
Uh...
How much?
How much is that budget?
Budget for...
What was that budget?
Okay.
It was like...
Two hundred to three hundred thousand dollars per episode...
Um...
So, each season would be like around six million, uh...
Like it was...
Yeah.
It was like two hundred to three hundred thousand dollars per episode.
But it...
Like if you see how the production ran for that, you'd understand it.
And then after...
Yeah, it was per episode.
Merch fucking sold a lot though at least.
Anyway, I read that and then they tried to make a sequel for it but oh my god.
The quality.
The quality of that sequel was wow-wee.
I was like looking at the animation quality.
I was like wow-wee.
That anime.
That's definitely not $200-300,000 per episode anymore.
Whoa.
Anyway.
Anyway, that's how I feel.
I feel like if we do a sequel to Kids Next Door now, the quality for that is gonna deteriorate so...
It's like those who were so hyped about Mega Man and people were so hyped because they were like, Mega Man's gonna get a sequel and a show?
Oh, okay.
Not Mega Man.
Megamind!
Sorry, Megamind.
Megamind is gonna get a sequel movie and a show?
And everyone was so hyped.
And people found out Will Ferrell wasn't gonna reprise his role as Mega Man.
And then that's when we all know things are not gonna be as good as it seems.
And then the trailer dropped.
And then that's when everybody really knew, oh, it's that type of sequel.
And that's why I hope that Galactic Kids Next Door stays fucking dead.
Because I feel like it's gonna be very similar.
I could feel that...
If you wait too long...
But not long enough...
I feel like if you wait too long but not long enough, the sequel will be really bad.
But if you wait...
Really long!
Really, really long!
That like...
It's like some fucking 90s, 80s shit that you're rebooting.
Then it'll be okay.
Because then like...
Those people who reboot something...
That long...
They wanna make sure they take really good care of the image of that.
Like the reimagining of it.
But like...
I heard the new X-Men animated show was like pretty decent too.
Um...
Yeah, is it X-Men...
There's a new X-Men show...
That seems to...
That's like really good animation-wise.
And...
I haven't watched it yet.
But I heard the new X-Men animated show was like...
Animation-wise...
Was really good.
I haven't watched it yet.
I really love...
I love the animated X-Men.
Not the...
Not the OG animated X-Men.
The one where they were like...
Fucking kid...
Like...
Not... Sorry.
Where they were...
Teenagers.
Okay, they were always teenagers.
But the one where they were like...
It was like...
High school drama.
You know?
Where...
They were like...
Which one was it?
Which X-Men was that?
The one where they was like...
High school drama.
Almost every episode.
I was like...
X-Men Evolution!
Yes!
I loved X-Men Evolution.
That shit was...
That shit...
Slaps.
Um...
I love X-Men Evolution.
But I think the funniest thing they did...
With...
Uh...
The funniest thing about the...
The new X-Men show...
Is that they changed...
Uh...
Okay, what's his name?
They...
Uh...
Fuck!
What was his name?
Um...
Okay, X-Men 97 characters...
They like changed people's powers.
Because they're like...
Oh, this is actually what it's like.
And I thought it was...
So funny.
Uh...
Cyclops!
I don't know why I forgot Cyclops.
I'm sorry.
My brain isn't working.
Um...
So...
Cyclops powers now.
So like...
If you guys didn't know...
It was so funny.
When I read the explanation...
When I read the explanation for Cyclops powers now...
So like...
You know how like...
We all know...
It's laser eyes.
Right?
So...
Appar...
Like the reason why...
So...
We all know...
It's like laser eyes.
Like the normies.
I.e.
Me.
Or like laser eyes.
Yeah.
Laser beams.
It shoots lasers.
But now...
Modern wise...
It's kinetic blast.
And now you guys are thinking...
Oh, Doki.
What do you mean by kinetic blast?
Apparently his eyes are portals to the fucking punch universe?
And the punch dimension?
And I...
And his eyes pull out these punch lasers from a different dimension.
So when he opens his eyes...
The lasers punches you.
And I thought...
I was like...
And it's like a fist.
So they're not actual like laser beams.
Like you know...
Superman lasers.
It's like a punch laser.
But like...
The normies always thought they were you know...
Superman lasers and it's through this ad...
New ad...
Cause they're...
Someone posted a fucking clip.
No.
It's...
I'm not...
It's called the punch dimension.
His eyes are portals to the punch dimension so that when he opens his eyes, he's punching people with his eye lasers.
I thought that was the dumbest thing I've ever read but it was also pretty funny.
Okay.
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Does Velma count as a reboot of a series of Scooby?
We don't talk about Velma.
Do not hate watch Velma!
I know!
No, Matt, please!
I beg of you!
Stop hate watching things!
Because the moment you start hate watching things, you're gonna give it attention and a reboot.
Or not reboot, a renewal of a series.
Please don't.
We don't need another season of Velma.
Um, please stop hate watching.
The only reason why Velma got another season is because we all hate watched it.
You know what fucking sucked?
The thing that sucked the most is that the animation quality for Velma is actually pretty good.
That's the worst part.
Like, I actually really like the animation budget for this.
Because they actually go hard on, like, the animation budget for this.
And I think that's the reason why I hate watching it.
Because I also hate watched it.
I was part of the problem.
I hate, I hate, I was also part of the problem.
But the fucking animation quality was so good!
The writing was fucking terrible, of course.
But, like, oh my god.
The fucking...
The...
Okay, by the way.
Not only did I...
...
Guys!
I need you all to stop hate watching Velma.
Because I already hate watched season two.
And I need you guys to stop because I already did my part.
And I need you guys to be stronger than me.
I need...
I need you...
I need you all to be stronger than me.
...
Look, it's not just me!
That's why I watched it!
I want you guys to be stronger!
...
Okay.
No I'll tell you the story.
I'll tell you the story of Velma.
I'll tell you season two.
Okay.
Scrappy Doo comes back in season two.
And I swear to god I need this guy to stop being in every animated show.
Not Scrappy Doo.
But the guy who fucking voices Scrappy Doo.
So, who voices Scrappy Doo?
Okay?
Okay, it is.
I need to fucking... okay, I need to like look up his name because I never remember his name.
But his fucking voice is so iconic.
So the person is Jason Menzucas.
And you guys are like, who's that?
He has been in every fucking animated show lately because his voice is so recognizable.
But he only voices as himself.
That's the... he only plays himself.
I swear to God, every... he has been typecasted as himself.
Every time.
It's some... okay, not himself, but like some fucking crazy dude.
It's always some fucking crazy dude.
He's in everything now.
And I'm tired.
Like he has a great voice, but I'm fucking tired of hearing him right now.
I'm fucking tired of hearing him in every animated show I'm watching.
It's just because he just plays the same guy.
Anyway, he's Scrappy-Doo, by the way.
He's uh... uh... he's... he plays as Scrappy-Doo.
And let me tell you the whole story.
Okay, I'm gonna... I'm gonna tell you season two of Velma.
Because like I don't want you guys to watch Velma.
Like I... I did it for you, chat.
I fucking...
I hate watch Velma.
So you don't have to hate watch Velma.
So we won't give Velma season three.
So...
So the thing is...
Okay, the thing is...
So Shaggy... who is it?
Norville?
Okay, by the way, Shaggy isn't called Shaggy anymore.
He's called Norville.
But the... and so like Norville starts...
Like in season one, he doesn't eat anything.
It's... it's not Shaggy.
Like in season one...
Like he doesn't eat anything.
He doesn't like snack at all.
He like... he still wears his like green shirt or whatever.
But he doesn't have a dog or anything.
And he doesn't, you know...
He...
We all know Shaggy was, you know...
Like... like woo Molly, you know?
Okay, so...
Norville does not do any of that.
And in season two, he starts having like hallucinations.
And like he starts having hallucinations.
And like starts getting triggered by...
By like...
Because he killed Fred's mom.
So he keeps having hallucinations.
And like triggered hallucinations.
And like trauma and stuff.
And the only way to stop his hallucination is to eat.
So then throughout the season, he...
He snacks and eats a lot.
Because he wants to stop the hallucinations.
Hahahaha!
Mochi, thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
He's like, the only way to stop my hallucination is if I snack on something.
Quick Velma, give me a snack!
Like...
And then...
And...
Yeah, he kills Fred's...
Yeah, he kills Fred's mom.
So he has like hallucinations.
But don't worry, Fred's mom was a bad person.
Anyway, the Hex sisters are back.
But they're old.
The Hex sisters has a cameo.
By being like...
Like...
Like roommates with Daphne's parents.
And...
So like one of the...
It's like one of the Hex sisters.
And then like she has a child.
She's like old.
The Hex sister is old now.
It's one Hex sister, by the way.
It's one Hex sister.
And she's our mom now.
And she has a child who's a teenager.
Who are staying over at Daphne's place.
Because they're broke or something.
Because they're open a witch store.
Anyway, none of that is important.
The whole plot is some fucking brain switching plot.
Because Norville's fucking grandmother is a scientist.
Who was working on a thing called Project Scooby.
And you're like, what's Project Scooby?
Well, Project Scooby is like the brain swapping operation thing.
So he like...
Norville found out that his grandmother never died.
And she was actually hiding out in the facility.
Where she helps soldiers and helps people find their true self.
By swapping their brains into a jar.
So they can find themselves.
And like when they are in a jar.
When they're a brain in a jar.
They realize what they want to be in the future.
Because they're like, you know, they're just a brain in a jar.
So they can like figure out what's their purpose.
And after they figure out their purpose in life.
She swaps the brain back into that first body.
So that's what Project Scooby is.
But then there is a hidden person called Uncle Scooby.
And people are trying to figure out who is the secret identity of Uncle Scooby.
And the thing about that is that they created Uncle Scooby.
And the military created a project.
Using the research from...
From Norval's grandmother.
To make Scrappy Doo.
And Scrappy Doo is like a fucking murderer.
Like because...
The story starts off...
Let me just say.
The story starts off in season 2.
Where there has been murders.
And then they were wondering who committed these murders.
And so they were trying to figure out who the fuck committed all these murders.
And then later on.
They found out that these people died.
By having their dicks bit off.
So...
So people were like...
Oh my god!
All these middle aged men are getting their dicks bit off!
What's going on?
And they were like...
And we discovered it was Scrappy Doo this entire time.
Uh...
So...
Um...
First...
First one.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll do anything for you to stop anything.
You know what to do.
So...
Anyway...
Um...
So...
Anyway...
The ending of the story is that everyone tries to stop Scrappy Doo from fucking biting their dicks.
Pay for my silence.
So...
People are trying to fucking...
Um...
People are trying to figure out like how to stop Scrappy Doo from killing everybody.
And it ends...
I'll just skip to the ending chat.
And it basically ends where Scrappy...
Um...
Where Velma sacrifices her life...
Uh...
To...
To help stop Scrappy Doo from killing everybody.
And then...
She possesses...
And then Scrappy Doo...
And then like a fucking missile.
Oh yeah!
The military sends a missile at the school.
Uh...
And...
And then...
And it hits Scrappy Doo.
Uh...
But Scrappy Doo survives.
But...
Uh...
Velma doesn't survive.
And then Scrappy Doo was like getting ready to kill the rest of the...
The rest of the gang.
And then he got possessed and died of a heart attack.
I don't fucking know how he actually died.
It just showed him getting possessed.
And then we found out...
Velma becomes a ghost...
And ghosts are real!
People are like, oh my god, wait, ghosts are real?
And then, um... and then, this season ends with the fact that, uh, the season ends with them being like, what do we do?
And Velma was like, do I go to the light?
Or do I stay here and try to figure things out?
And then the Hex sister, like, daughter was like, don't worry, Velma, I know a way to get your body back.
And, but I will need to study for, we gotta wait until the summer.
I need to study all these witch books to figure out how to get your body back, Velma.
And then the show ends.
And that was the end of the season.
The end of season two.
Look, I actually, like, took out all the fucking filler in between, so you're welcome, guys.
Cause there was, there was a lot of things going on in between every, cause like, there was one where, um, Velma's mom gets together with Fred's dad.
And, um, and then Velma's, Velma's dad's, um...
new wife.
Like, Velma's stepmom, uh, got together, like, Velma's stepmom was actually Uncle Scooby this entire time.
Um, who was working behind the scenes undercover as a waitress.
Um, and like, purposely tried to, like, uh, get close to Velma's dad so that she could get more information regarding, like...
Regarding Project Scooby.
Like...
Um...
Anyway, Mercy, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we never speak of Velma again?
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
And then, thank you for the Super Chat!
My brain hurts.
Anyway!
Now you guys don't have to watch Velma season two.
Cause all you need to know is that Scrappy-Doo is in it.
And he was biting.
And people were like, who...
The first episode is like, who are the murderers?
It was Scrappy-Doo.
He was the one that bit him.
He bit everybody's dick off.
Anyway!
Also!
By the way...
Oh yeah, Velma and Daphne are dating too.
I don't know if that's relevant.
And Norville's dating a fucking brain.
And then...
Fred is just very stupid.
Like...
He has like, mommy and daddy issues.
And then he's like, I'm just a baby.
Um, wait, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
This is my second time listening to your stream.
How this evolved into Velma season two.
I don't know.
All I know is that I am playing a train simulator.
Chuckling my ass off about how badly written Velma is.
I think I'll stay with Ghost in a Shell standalone complex.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Um...
Anyway.
Anyway, that was Velma Season 2.
And after all of that, I will have this...
Okay, to be fair, I have a confession.
I watched Episode 1 to 5 of Season 2 and then skipped to the last episode.
Because I was like...
Because there was no progression, I swear.
The progression of the story, the progression of Season 2 was like 99% filler.
And then 1% of the actual plot.
So I was like, who the fuck is the murderer?
I was so... I swear to God, I couldn't...
Like, I was just like, who the fuck is the murderer?
I was just... where?
Where?
Every time it's just a filler episode.
I swear, it was like we make 1% progress of the fucking show plot.
And then everything else was like, Fred has mommy issues.
How is he gonna solve that?
And like, um...
And Norville suddenly has no empathy.
But don't worry, he's just gonna get it back in like the next episode or something.
I was like, where's the progression?
And I was like...
I just wanna know who the fuck is the murderer that's biting off people's dicks?
Who is it?
Like...
It's like, at first you're like, oh, somebody's chopping off their dicks.
And I was like, oh my God, who the fuck is killing people by chopping off their dicks?
And then they're like...
Oh, my God, we find out it's Scrappy-Doo fucking eating it.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
And I got shown that in the last episode.
Like, I didn't find that out until the last episode where I just skipped to the final episode to figure out what the fuck is going on.
Like...
I need to take a break, Dookie.
I'm sorry, this is too much.
Anyway...
Despite all of that...
I hate how good the animation is.
Like, the quality of the visuals for Velma is too good for what the show is about.
And it hurts.
It actually is not fair.
It's not fair at all.
Why is the quality so good?
There was like moments in there where I was like, wow.
The animation and the face animation and the visuals.
And the...
There were moments where they do like insane shading and like expressions and everything.
And I'm like, why does this look so good?
Why does this look so fucking good for the show I'm watching?
Anyway...
I hate watch that show.
So you don't have to watch it.
Please do not give...
Please do not give Velma another hate watch.
I beg of you.
It does not deserve a season 3.
I swear to God.
I know you guys are like now super curious.
But I swear to God.
It was...
It sounds better than what it actually is.
Like Scooby's not even in it, guys.
Scooby Doo isn't even in it, chat.
Like Scooby Doo isn't even in it, chat.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
There was...
That was...
I can't believe I said majority of this chatting stream today.
Just talking about animation.
I was just incredibly passionate, chat.
I was so fucking passionate.
Jumping on to another topic.
What the fuck is Tarkov doing?
Did you guys hear about it?
I didn't like...
I never like joined...
I never played Tarkov.
But like...
For those who don't know...
Tarkov like basically like a little...
I guess like...
Speed run of what's going on right now.
Tarkov basically tried to release a game that was like 200 plus dollars.
And people were like what the fuck.
It's like this pay to win...
Oh yeah, and it's like pay to win DLC.
And basically...
Sort of killed Tarkov at the moment.
But like not fully.
Because I was talking to one of my friends.
And I was...
Because like they love Tarkov.
And I was like yo...
And they were like I don't know what to play.
And then I was like what do you want to play?
And they were like I'm going to play Tarkov.
And I was like what the fuck?
They were like...
What do you mean?
Why are you playing Tarkov?
Didn't like shit happen?
And then my friend was like...
My friend...
He was like...
Oh it was on sale.
Because of all that drama.
It was like...
It was like oh yeah.
You know like after everything they put it on sale.
And I was like I couldn't miss the opportunity.
Like...
Yeah.
I think it was like $50 or something.
He was like...
Oh yeah.
I don't know when it's going to be like $50 again.
I might as well like buy the dip.
Yeah.
Because of everything that's going on at the moment.
Tarkov decided to do like a huge fucking sale.
To like convince people that they're like thinking about the consumers now.
And they're like sorry for the misuse of the internet.
And they're like...
I don't know what mistake we made.
But we're gonna...
Gaming marketing is so...
It is.
I talked about this before.
Because it doesn't matter how much like Nintendo does.
The moment they release a new Legend of Zelda.
You guys will just eat that shit up.
It doesn't matter what they do.
Like...
The gaming audience is so easy to manipulate.
Like did you guys heard?
About...
About like...
The Garry's Mod shit.
Like did you guys...
You sell that?
Where?
Where like...
It's like okay the new...
The Garry's Mod thing where...
We don't know if it's actually Nintendo.
Like people don't know for sure yet.
But basically the whole gist is that...
Nintendo filed like copyright takedowns on...
On...
On Garry's Mod.
And...
Garry's Mod now has to take down like...
20 years worth of Nintendo IP stuff.
In Garry's Mod.
And that's 20 years.
It was so sad.
That the devs of Garry's Mod...
Was like...
Please it would help so much if you guys could take it down yourself.
Because there's 20 years of...
There's 20 years of content.
And it's so much to do.
And...
People were like please.
And just don't re-upload it.
And like the fucking devs...
Was like please.
Take it down for us.
And...
But like...
It's not the first time.
And it's not going to be the last.
And like the moment they release something...
Oh my gosh.
And then Nintendo's gonna be like...
Guys we're gonna make a Legend of Zelda movie.
And you guys would just forget.
And then...
You guys would be like next Nintendo Direct.
Oh my god.
Nintendo Direct.
Yes.
Gamers are just so easy to...
Fucking...
Like we're very simple minded.
I'm simple minded.
I would know.
Um...
That's...
I can still...
It's just...
That's what I'm saying.
There's just so simple minded.
That would be like...
Oh my god.
Fucking 80% off of Tarkov.
Might as well.
Like...
We don't know when that's gonna happen again.
It just sucks.
Cause like Tarkov is like one of the only...
It's only if somebody makes a better...
Better Tarkov-esque game.
Cause like...
Every time somebody tries to do like a...
Um...
A version of Tarkov, it dies.
Like...
Who is that one?
The one with the space one.
The Psycho?
The Psycho died so fast.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I spent money on that game.
I'm so sad.
Yeah.
80% off $250.
What a fucking steal.
Yeah.
Psycho.
Frontiers.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Spyro's don't forget.
Yes, but they're still playing Smash though.
Do you really never forget?
If you're still trying to like play Smash Brothers.
And also trying to...
Trying to set up tournaments despite like...
Despite like everything Nintendo tries to do against it.
Like...
If you never forget, you just leave.
But...
Smash Brothers don't leave.
They stay.
It's just torture at that point.
Like...
Yeah!
Um...
Cass!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like I still buy Pokemon plushies.
I still love Pokemon.
I'm still gonna...
Like I know my place.
Stop it hurts.
They're in their own little purgatory.
We're all part of the problem.
What?
Darkblade!
What other games can we play?
Oh my god!
That's so...
That's so sad.
What other games do we play?
Don't talk to me.
What else is there?
That's what I'm saying.
It doesn't matter.
We...
There's nothing we can do.
Actually sad.
Oh my god.
Oh!
That was...
I think I'm gonna call it here guys.
I think I'm gonna call it here chat.
I had...
I had a great time hanging out with you guys today.
Dragoons.
It was a nice...
Nice Goodnight Dragoons radio session today that we had.
And obviously I always enjoy just hanging out with you guys.
And just like...
Talking...
Sad ending!
I'm
saying!
I love...
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
But did you guys see...
Did you guys see...
Okay I'm trying to think of something positive to say.
I'm trying... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Doki Amber Doge was so cute today guys!
I'm gonna pause it.
Um... Because like...
Um...
Today... Today he keeps like dropping off...
Like little...
Little like toys and stuff.
Every time like I let him up on my bed.
To like sleep with me.
And he always like just like brings a toy...
Over...
Brings a toy over.
And now like I realize... There's like a lot of toys.
There's like a whole stash of like toys.
There's toys and stuff at the end of my bed.
It's so fucking cute.
Anyway!
Oh yes!
The convention!
If you guys didn't know!
If you guys didn't know...
I'm going to be...
At Anime North!
It's actually my very very first Canadian convention!
Like I've never... It's actually crazy.
As a Canadian... Canadian bird...
I've never been to a...
I've never guested at a Canadian convention before.
I was really excited to...
Have this opportunity.
I'll only be there for a panel for one day.
It's going to be like 8.30pm EST.
Eastern because Anime North is on East Coast.
But...
I'm going to be doing a...
Q&A panel for an hour.
On Friday I believe.
So it is in Canada!
It's in Canada!
And it's going to be the first convention for my Doki World Tour.
So there's going to be many more conventions...
In the future.
And...
So please look forward to it!
So there's no meet and greet for this one.
But that doesn't mean there wouldn't be meet and greets...
In the future for the other conventions.
A huge shout out for Anime North because they actually...
Fit me in last minute.
Because I saw their request a little bit...
Late and they fit me in...
Last minute so they weren't able to...
Set up like meet and greets and stuff due to how...
Last minute it was.
So yes!
I think I asked if I could...
Like they like requested for me...
Like...
They like requested for me a while back...
And then I saw the email...
For it.
Like me and my team saw...
The email for it last month because it got lost.
So I was like oh I really want to start...
I really want to do a convention in May.
And then we like...
And we were able to get in last minute...
For a...
For a panel with them.
So I'm super excited.
Anyway!
I'll see you guys...
There!
At Anime North!
Anyway guys as always everybody...
Stay hydrated, pause, check, get up...
And move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!
Also I know I said like next week...
There was going to be two collabs.
It's going to be one collab because the other one...
Got rescheduled.
It was supposed to be a singing lessons...
With Yusan next week.
But then we had like conflict of schedule.
Between the two of us.
So we decided to reschedule that to...
Two weeks later.
I don't remember the exact date.
But like that's why it's going to be one collab.
Next week instead.
So next I have two.
So just look forward to that other collab.
Soon-ish.
I think it's going to be like in two weeks or something.
Anyway!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!